luke and tom here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're here with my
brother and his son on a remote island
in alaska and we've been camping
fishing
spear fishing
and having a good time haven't we yeah
[Music]
this'll be fun
it will be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we're here with john
who's going to be our captain and we're
with coldwater alaska and we're going to
be spearfishing rod reel fishing
camping it's going to be awesome and
look at this weather guys we couldn't
ask for better weather than this
all right we're just taking a little
stop to drop a chum bag down in this
cove and this might be a spot we hit
later on but uh look how pretty it is
and there's just sea otters everywhere
got a brick of frozen chum and a little
herring oil on a paper towel we're gonna
drop that down in a crab bait bag
let that soak and bring in the fish
dan's wasting no time here he's uh spot
sampling yes i am goals
all right gotta jump overboard to keep
heading down the coast
[Music]
there's a whale right in front of us i
think it might be a humpback i saw it i
think there's another one
yeah right there see the sound there's
the tail
this is amazing
[Music]
if you guys want to throw the buzz bomb
down there's this cool spot right here
here i want you to hold the rod
we're just heading to a spearfishing
spot and we saw some signals on the fish
finder so we're just going to drop some
lures down and see if we can't pick
something up real quick
you want to reel it in yes come here
here go ahead all you buddy
let's see what you got tom let's see
what you got
little grilling
oh they're pretty there you go
how pretty that sucker is yeah
yeah little
got something
oh another green wing that's a prettier
yeah they're pretty oh nice dad here let
me get pop them off
there you go pretty fish huh yeah
now those are called greenling and while
they're a gorgeous fish and they make
great lean cog bait they're not the best
table fare so we'll just send those one
back we're gonna get some better fish
today all right that was a fun little
drift we're gonna pick it up go try
another spot
oh look at the harlequins oh this is so
cute out of this
got a little spot here a little bit of
kelp right depth
visibility's not horrible
yeah
yeah that's a nice little black rock
fish
it's exactly what we're looking for
all right
okay oh thank you
chuck them in there
[Music]
oh another one that's a nice one
well i'm getting geared up the guys are
jigging for black rock fish and so far
you already got two in the boat right oh
there you go really really right here oh
kelp grilling
yeah nice i knew something was fighting
you got another one tommy here yeah
that's a big one yeah we're just hitting
them one after another
all right
all right guys this is my first time
diving in alaska and it was so different
than anything i've done before it's like
diving in an underwater forest you've
got these massive 30 foot tall bull kelp
plants all around you and you're just
swimming through leaves it's really a
unique experience
my spear broke off into it flagged
no i don't i don't have the equipment to
fix it if i if i did
now our target species was rockfish and
halibut and one of the big techniques we
used was to go slightly downstream from
the chum bag and hide in the weeds and
you'd sit there in this little snowing
chum and wait for a halibut or a
rockfish to come up we'd see lots of
these kelp greenling
and i was doing this right by the boat
and so i could actually watch my brother
fish and he was literally out fishing me
while i was sitting there trying to look
for a rock
go fish and do this
you know just bask in the sun like a fat
seal on a rock there's a reason why they
do it i just hope anything's happening
but
hey tom
you having fun yes
take a hot shower here
that helps get the feeling back in my
feet
but my socks are a lot hot water bottles
now
we didn't see a lot of fish just a
couple of black rock fish and a whole
bunch of kelp greeling but
we're gonna go pick up and try another
spot one of these other places we jumped
up well so far dan's been the one
tearing it up he's got three uh black
rockfish in the coolers
something little this is a big this is a
heavy rock
he almost looks like a link cup that's a
baby ling dude it's a baby
yeah
it was a good eating but not legal
yeah it's a little small too yeah
multiple levels of illegality
all right dad what you got no idea
there you go
that guy hit it hard
hey
dozens of sea otters yeah you see little
babies riding on their tummies
all right we're back at this jump bag we
dropped earlier we go dive on it see
what's there
this next spot was really different from
the other one there was mostly sand and
it was wide open so i'd go and i'd shake
up the chum and i'd sit there and look
for halibut in the sand and they're
really camouflaged you have to look
really hard
after kind of making circles around the
chum bag i'd go downstream in a zigzag
pattern looking for any halibut or
rockfish that were following the chum
back to the chum bag and we saw lots of
really cool stuff there was starfish and
you noticed there was all of these
little dimples and depressions on the
bottom those were caused by sea otters
where they would dive down and dig up
the clams and eat them we also saw a
little baby halibut little one-inch
halibut hiding in the sand
but one of the coolest things was we
started to hear orcas
right out over here
yeah yeah
for the next hour there was a pot of
orcas hunting salmon right around the
boat we got to see them jump and breach
and hunt it was really cool but it was
creepy having an 8 000 pound predator
bouncing sonar waves off his wallet
hunted
i could hear him down there you can hear
him talking yeah under the water though
upset stomach
i didn't see any halibut but there were
a ton of greenling in this spot and they
would come right up to you and you could
get so close to them i was very tempted
to take a shot on several occasions
at one point one of them was even close
enough that i could just touch him with
the tip of my spear
poke
i am frozen i need to get some more hot
water in my wetsuit
ah it's better
well we saw some flounders i saw a quite
ton of
kelp greely
you guys having fun yeah yeah
[Music]
i'm gonna do a quick dive on another
spot
yeah
like it's totally
[Music]
most of these dive spots was in about 35
feet of water and we'd sit just
downstream from these chum bags looking
for halibut swimming through the kelp so
we could ambush them
you'd also kind of look in these sand
patches to try to see if you could have
any halibut you had to get down low to
try to see if you could see their
profile in the sand
after my
fourth fifth or sixth hot shower seventh
hot shower we're gonna we're gonna try
another spot but we're gonna
do a little jigging on the way over here
maybe we'll pull something out
this is the worst point right here
it's calm enough it's up to you
check out their seals right there
this final spot we dove down on the chum
bag and we saw a bit of cod sitting
there you can see right there there's
like a little cod
right on the chum bag and i thought
about shooting him but then i just let
him go
but i'd go downstream in the chum slick
and saw lots of kelp greenling and
sculpin but no halibut my brother
however had loads of luck catching cod
and kelp gurley
man look at that champion
like this my fish don't jiggle jiggle he
folds you know i'm actually
a lot warmer
now than i was last one
oh well i am totally gassed guys
but it's been awesome but uh john's just
being an absolute champ he's putting in
a lot of work to try to get us on fish
and uh he's gonna take us to one last
jigging spot
before we camp for the night we're gonna
see if we can't catch a few black path
feels feels good to be warm
all right you tell us when you read the
drop
hey yeah dan's got something
i got rock fish but it's not yeah it's
it's one of you is that like a dusky or
something little baby dusky it looks
like you're dragging your lines i'm just
gonna put hey
[Music]
i've never seen one of those i think
that's the non-polar the non-pelagic if
i remember correctly oh that's
you can keep you can keep one of those
oh yeah sure reel that in tom reel that
dusky
oh
okay john does the sickest eagle call
i've ever heard
there you go tom
get him tom get him
nice tom oh look at that lizard fish
that's a decent one
i oh i got a fight
oh tommy tommy's got a lizard fish i had
it on for a long time
oh that was awesome we caught so many
rock fish but we're gonna just mosey on
down here and see if we can't snag a
salmon just for a minute or two before
we call it
right there oh my god yeah
wait wait wait wait wait where
pulled this boat into this little slough
here and there we can see salmon it's
just crystal clear and we're trying to
use rock fishing jigs
to get them
get them low get them low get them low
as they go
down
there you go there you go bring it
around to the side ready and one two
three oh no oh
he broke there
right there oh he's dead
oh my gosh
i hooked a beautiful red we got him up
and he broke off as we're getting him
over the rail
but he was so fatigued he just kind of
went down and went belly up so i tried
to get the gaff to get him
almost fell over and somebody grabbed my
heel and kept me from going over and
then
that was done and then my glasses went
in and i managed to get those so that
was a lot of fun
really sketchy
all right guys
oh that was so awesome but we gotta get
going it's getting late and we still
need to set up our camp
[Applause]
oh
a ride no way getting off this island
until john comes back for us
i'm hungry i'm very hungry
look at this is the this is a root ball
right here
gray tinder
i'm sorry
how would they have blood in them well i
think it's time to start cooking some
dinner and we've got some hamburgers to
cook so
i am really looking forward to that
we got some ketchup tomatoes and we've
got onions lettuce
what do you think tom burger tastes good
yeah
the hamburgers were good but they
disappeared a little too quickly i think
we need to go flare up some of those
fish
grizzly bear would have to like swim
over here oh i did it
but my legs have gone numb oh boy there
we go nice pile of fish fillets
[Music]
all right i got some sweet chili sauce
and mayo here i'm going to put on my
fish burger
there we go fish burger
very little sleep
i really like rockfish
well guys it is late and i am exhausted
so i'm gonna hit the sack
but uh we've got a full day here
tomorrow
and uh cross our fingers
there aren't any bears on this island
because we've got food laying around
everywhere
and we reconfish
it's hard to communicate to you at home
how much of an incline there is in this
tent i feel like i'm sliding down a hill
in a potato sack
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i have the high ground it's over
etiquette tommy take my head
don't let go be brave
well it is a gorgeous day today look at
this
all right guys well i'm gonna go ahead
and start cooking some breakfast and i
think my brother here is gonna go try
some surf fishing
i got breakfast simmering over the fire
oh look at all the mussels here
look at that
tommy and ben have been beach coleman
let's go see what they found
oh look at that starfish that is a cool
one we're looking for octopus i want to
eat one
the starfish
put a house
all right
sitting there cleaning up the campsite
and dan's got a fish
a lot of seaweed
you know what that's like a little cod
thing yeah
yeah look at that little tom cod
how long has been on there there you go
ben
there you go
oh brother
you want some popcorn yes all right i'll
give you some popcorn let's go all right
baby
die
there you go
watch out watch out watch out
[Music]
tommy like that
good
it's been a lovely low-key morning we
went and shot the 22 a little bit me and
tommy went and explored the island but
we got word the boat's going to pick us
up in about 30 minutes so uh we're going
to kind of get everything packed up and
stacked up on the water's edge get ready
for the boat
here comes a ride
[Music]
uh
well john thank you so much for an
awesome trip we had such a great time
listen guys if you're ever in homer
alaska and you'd like to do this too
make sure to check out coldwater alaska
i'll put a link in the video description
below
thanks for coming with us awesome
uh our mail
we're a little hungry so we got a pizza
for me and dan
oh that looks good
you got that
okay that's heavy go take the pizza box
inside
listen guys that was an awesome trip i
hope you guys have enjoyed this video if
you want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel make sure
to click subscribe we've got tons of
videos and check out our playlist thanks
for watching have a great day i'll see
you guys next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]